in the early hours of january 3rd 2020
shortly after arriving at baghdad
international airport
major general assem soleimani was killed
in a u.s drone strike
his close ally the deputy head of iraq's
popular mobilization forces
abu mehti al-mohandas also died along
with eight others
missiles from the u.s drone hit their
convoy as it left the airport
suleimani was the commander of the cots
force a unit of iran's revolutionary
guard
responsible for foreign operations and
he was also considered to be the second
most powerful man in iran
behind the country's supreme leader
ayatollah ali
the news of his death made official by
iran's state tv
a three-day morning period was announced
and iran vowed revenge
as u.s president donald trump stood by
his decision
with this claim last night at my
direction the united states military
executed a flawless strike that
terminated
the terrorist ringleader responsible for
gravely wounding and murdering
thousands and thousands of people
and hundreds and hundreds at least of
americans
qasem solomoni has been killed
and his bloody rampage is now forever
gone for ayatollah khamenei
soleimani was a trusted confidante a
member of his inner circle
and a friend for more than 30 years
almost 12 months on
the commander-in-chief of iran's armed
forces says
he's not done avenging soleimani's death
whenever it's possible we will take
revenge we will take revenge on those
who ordered soleimani's assassination
and the ones who carried out that
assassination just hours after
soleimani's body was laid to rest in his
hometown of cairmon
on january 7th the revolutionary guard
launched 13 missiles at the u.s
base anal assad in iraq no americans
were killed
but tensions increased iran was on high
alert
and accidentally shot down a ukrainian
airline passenger plane
killing all 176 people on board
while the united states said they were
not seeking regime change in iran
trump's decision to kill rasim soleimani
had far-reaching repercussions
feared by his enemies inside iran
salimani had for years been one of the
most popular national figures in the
country
the international face of iranian
resistance to american pressure
he remained largely untouched by the
diminishing popularity of the country's
elected government
his death prompted calls for the
expulsion of u.s troops from the middle
east
by iranian officials as well as
iranian-backed groups in iraq
and it's a demand which still stands a
year later
officials here called soleimani's
assassination a new chapter in the
history of the middle east
while many countries condemn the act no
one has actually been held accountable
despite efforts by iran to prosecute u.s
president donald trump through interpol
soleimani's role was quickly failed by
his deputy
but his legacy is now entrenched in
iran's history
dorsojabari al jazeera tehran